we're here at Comic Con 2015 I'm Justin
this is mike gonzalez the head of
consumer products here at what a
workshop now when is definitely well
known for creating some of the most
beloved props in The Lord of the Rings
movies and we know that they're also
working on the warcraft movie this stuff
we see behind us well what do you got
showing off here at a comic con well
we're out here showing this the artistry
of what it works up we've obviously
designed and built all the lord of the
rings in the middle earth series hobbit
and now we're expanding like you said
into work crap but we also have worked
on everything from Avatar district nine
most recently chappie we even did
concept design for fury road so we're
really out here to showcase all the
different facets of wetta and the
different properties and our new
relationship with legendary pictures and
some of the props you have here are
these actually use in the movies or
these just replicas that you guys have
brought along so everything you see
above us over here with the armor those
are all actually used in the films for
work crap chappie that we see on the
other side he was at one of the extra
robots in the film so all the physical
robots that were built we even built the
full-size moose and now we're doing the
scale one yeah so pretty much everything
you see here is actual props are created
just for comic-con
so here's a boot showing off obviously
some of the weapons and armor what what
is this exactly so this is one of the
Royal Guards for the warcraft film you
can see all the artists of the workshop
that we kind of got the process that you
go through when you build the armor we
help to work with them on all the
Alliance armor and weaponry and then
then along with every license that we do
we usually try to get the same artist to
go through and make some collectibles so
in this case we're doing some six scale
armor and weapons and we'll be coming
out with a few other things in the
Warcraft line too so
over here looks like we have a few more
weapons from the world of warcraft set
could you talk about these at all or are
these collectibles as well yes these are
all prop replicas that you can actually
buy and take home with you these are all
the Middle Earth lines so you got the
staff of Solomon bolands mace tarios
bows dwellings axes a lot of the fans
like to cosplay and they like to you
know display the pieces on the wall
sweet again these are all taken from the
original molds for the movie so these
would be the same weapons that that
graham mctavish would carry on his back
because the real weapons the hero metal
ones would be way too heavy and of
course building off of that more
futuristic line chappie I think is
something a lot more people are familiar
with as well that's right we we had a
lot of fun doing this one not only did
we do all the concept design for all the
robots we actually built all the robots
for the film itself so every physical
robot that you saw in the film was built
in the wedo workshop and put together on
the set so everything from the 12-foot
tall moose that hugh jackman works on
and brings to life to all our backup
police droids and chappy himself and was
this a prompt that was used in the film
the one you brought here with you today
yeah this this guy here is the chappie
robot he's not the original chappie
robot he was one of the police droids
and we modified him for our display but
he is one of the robots that was used in
the film that was built and then what we
have here is a prop or collectible that
we're going to bring out of the moose
statutes that will be coming out in the
first quarter of 2016 and of course
building off of that more futuristic
line chappie I think is something a lot
more people are familiar with as well
that's right we we had a lot of fun
doing this one not only did we do all
the concept design for all the robots we
actually built all the robots for the
film itself so every physical robot that
you saw in the film was built in the
wedo workshop and put together on the
set so everything from the 12-foot tall
moose that hugh jackman works on and
brings to life to all our backup police
droids and chappy himself and was this a
prompt that was used in the film the one
you brought here with you today yeah
this this guy here is the chappie robot
he's not the original chappie robot he
was one of the police droids and we
modified him for our display but he is
one of the robots that was used in the
film that was built and then what we
have here is a prop
lek table that we're going to bring out
of the moose statutes that will be
coming out in the first quarter of 2016
you have a ton of collectibles and a
line of people who are here to just buy
some cool stuff that that's what a theme
that sounds like what itself is growing
and becoming more than just a prop maker
but a company on its own yes that's one
of the things about the company
everybody likes to come and visit and
check out our booth but they also want
to take it have a takeaway or a
touchstone so what we're trying to do is
is to tap in each of the market come up
with pin lines with from the different
license that we work on but obviously
are larger and collectibles for the
different films and then just expand as
weight as we expand licenses we want to
expand our lines too and a lot of fans
look forward to what we're bringing out
this year well thanks so much for taking
the time to talk with us as we check out
all this cool comic con stuff and I know
what people are most excited about it
the gamespot audience is probably seeing
a little bit more of Warcraft and that's
coming out next year June of 2016 of the
exciting film yeah so look forward to
that and more of what what it has going
on on gamespot com
you